il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
de bonnes vacances
moi c'est nicolas et j'aimerais bien
vous raconter mes vacances alors alors
les enfants jusqu ici qui font du
tourisme
non mais ça va se lever la suivant me
suis déjà fait un tas de copains il ya
créé par yann blaise qui n'est pas en
vacances parce qu'ils habitent ici
respondents les gens via diodio jeux
d'eau et sept armes qui viennent chez
nous parce que chez eux ya pas de sonner
yako qui vont pourtant avoir raison et
c'est très énervant
et puis il ya fois que je me trouve au
même qu'est ce que ça même quand ça a
été déjà mangé
le début mes vacances je pas près d
oublier bien sûr les enfants